Womit assoziierst du Klettverschlüsse? Kindheit. Und zwar dieses, man wollte noch mal raus, es hat angefangen zu regnen, vorhin hat sich so eine schöne Pfütze vom Haus gebildet, wo man unbedingt draufspringen wollte. Und dann, kann ich noch mal raus, kann ich noch mal raus, Mama? Und dann hast du schön die Schuhe aufgemacht, weil die waren ja immer geschlossen, dann hast du diesen Klettverschluss aufgemacht, Schuhe rein, Klettverschluss zugemacht und rausgekauft. Ich glaube, die Benutzung von Klettverschluss ist eigentlich dem Alter entgegengesetzt. Ich glaube, je älter man wird, desto weniger Klettverschluss benutzt man. Außer dann gegen Ende dann wieder, wenn du dann vielleicht dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so dann diese abreissbaren Hosen, die ich ja genial finde, wo der Klettverschluss über das gesamte Hosenbein verteilt ist und du so von vorne einfach so die Hose wegreißen kannst. Kann man nicht kaufen. Ich habe mal geguckt, irgendwie Zerando oder so, aber da aus meinen Websites des Vertrauens gibt es halt diese Hosen nicht, oder? Wo kauft man die? Du, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich sehe die auch nur im Rahmen von Shows. Wo kauft man denn so große Zauberkisten, wo man Leute drin verschwinden lassen kann? Mit so Fragezeichen drauf, mit so kleinen Hüten drauf. Ja, mit so kleinen Sternchen und so, die so oft glänzend sind. Ich mag das Wort Bedarf. Immer wenn ich höre, Bedarf, habe ich Interesse. Heißt du, oh, erzähl mir mehr. Zaubererbedarf. Oh, super, geil. Der Nachmittag ist gelaufen. Ich bin jetzt in der Welt der Zauberer. Ich habe mal einen Linkshänderbedarf gefunden. Oh, wie Ned Flanders, Leftorium. Das ist ja geil. Und was gab es dann da alles? Sehr Scheren, sehr viele Scheren. Scheren sind ein großes Problem für Linkshänder. Linkshänder hassen offensichtlich Rechtshänderscheren. Was ja auch so ist, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Nagelschere hast, ist es ja eine Rechtshänderschere. Das heißt, du kannst dir die linken Fingernägel mit der rechten Hand gut schneiden. Wenn du dann aber versuchst, deine rechte Hand mit der linken Hand zu schneiden, geht's nicht. Wo man sich auch denkt, wie hat der Erfinder sich das gedacht? Und wie hat der Mensch bislang überlebt? Dass man geschnitten bekommt von jemand anderem oder dass man, das kann man nicht vorstellen, wie man das, also das ist ja ein Konzept, das so offensichtlich nicht funktioniert, weil das ja zwei Hände links und rechts und diese Nagelschere ist ja eigentlich nur dafür gedacht, die linken Hände zu schneiden. Ich finde, Nagelschere ist auch einfach, manche Erfindungen sind dann einfach irgendwann obsolet. Mit der Erfindung des Nagelknipsers finde ich den Scheren komplett irrelevant. Also herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-Ufo, Stefan, jetzt ist es noch nicht will. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, der Nagelknipser ist für mich nicht akzeptabel, weil der Nagelknipser einem eine Fingernagelkrümmung vorgibt, die ich nicht akzeptiere. So, jetzt kommt es aber an, wie du Nagelknipst. Du kannst ja auch alle Formen, du kannst ja auch kleine Quietsche-Äntchen reinschneiden, theoretisch, wenn du willst. Ja, aber du hängst ja dann, nee, ich bin auf jeden Fall dagegen. Und es ist ja tatsächlich so, zum Thema Nagelscheren ist es ja ein interessantes, sag ich mal, Spiel mit der weiblichen Lust. Lass mich näher darauf eingehen. Ich bin ganz gespannt. Es ist so, ich habe lange Zeit Gitarre gespielt und beim Gitarrespielen kommt man irgendwann an einen Punkt. Irgendwann kommst du an den Punkt, wo du deinen Körper beeinflussen musst, wo du anfängst, auch zum Gitarrenspieler zu werden. In dem Moment, wo, ich glaube, du willst darauf hinaus, die rechte Hand lässt du die Finger lang, um die Seiten weiter zupfen zu können. Richtig. Oh Gott, und links ist kurz, zu kurz. Dieses Weiße ist komplett verschwunden. Absolut, es gibt nur noch Pink, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und die Sache ist nämlich die, der Gitarrenlehrer, also mein Gitarrenlehrer hat dann irgendwann gesagt, Fronti, pass mal auf, du spielst jetzt schon seit 16 Jahren Gitarre, es wird schon langsam mal auf einer Zeit über Nagelzupfen nachzudenken. Und das war für mich echt so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, wow. Also das ist ja so, so Initiationsriten sind ja ganz wichtig in der menschlichen Kultur und die gibt es ja immer weniger. Früher gab es ja, wie zum Beispiel man in 300 gesehen hat, ja, jeder junge Mann, jeder junge Krieger muss irgendwann mal dann raus in die Wildnis alleine und wenn er es dann schafft, gegen den Wolf zu kämpfen, dann kehrt er zurück zum Stamm und ist Mann, hat sich verändert, ist jetzt Mann. Und davor war er Junge. Oder Batman, der dann in diesem festgesetzt wird und durch den Brunnen oben raus muss, wieder diesen komischen Gang, der seine Kinder... Ist dann Fledermausmann. Jede Kultur hat dann seine eigene Initiationsrichtos, aber sowas gibt es ja heute kaum noch. Also es gibt natürlich die Pubertät, aber wirklich jetzt so Punkte,
auch so Barmizwa und sowas sind ja auch so einschneidende Momente.
Auch damals die Sabinerinnen, die irgendwann angefangen haben,
bin ich so sehr Kriegerin, dass ich meine Brust abschneiden muss und dann angefangen haben, ihre Brüste abzuschneiden.
Aber nur die linke.
Genau, um den Arm besser ...
Nee, wegen dem Bogen.
Wegen dem Bogen besser fließend zu können.
Weil du sonst mit der Sehne immer in deine linke Brust reinzwirrest.
Scheiß linke Brust.
Ja, und dann haben die einfach abgeschnitten.
Und dann, was war dann da? Nichts. War ein großes Tattoo. Schwer zu sagen. Vor allem, wo kommt dann die Milch raus? Aus der anderen Brust, deswegen gibt es zwei Brüste. Ja, das weißt doch die Brust nicht, oder? Seitdem Sabine rin, haben die gesagt, fuck it, andere, lass eine andere wachsen, lass sie mal zwei, wir brauchen zwei. Oder wächst sie nach. Vielleicht ist das so wie Fingernäck. Aber ich habe ja gehört, dass du, wenn du jemanden stillst, also in der Regel dein Kind, dann musst du darauf aufpassen, dass du sozusagen wirklich so wie bei so linke und rechte Brust gleichmäßig beanspruchst, dass du nicht mit der linken Brust halt dann leer bist und auf der rechten dann noch deine ganzen Milchvorräte. Da musst du einfach Kopfstand machen, dann gleicht das wieder aus. Vielleicht kommen jetzt wieder Hassbeschwerden, dass ich mich nicht mit dem weiblichen Körper auskenne, aber das ist mir egal mittlerweile, das ist mir völlig egal. Es ist ja so ein bisschen wie man, ich meine, du bist ja jetzt der, wir kommen gleich noch zurück auf dieses Thema. Also du musstest dann nicht irgendwann aufgeben, um, also du musstest dann zum Gitarrenspieler werden. Du bist zu Fledermaus geworden, zum Fledermausmann, du bist zu Gitarrenmann geworden, hast dir die rechte Hand lang wachsen lassen, die linke kurz, oder? Genau, und es, Aber es ist wirklich so, und es ist ja interessant, weil da kommt man ja selber nicht drauf, und es ist tatsächlich so, dass du instant wesentlich besser spielst. Es ist natürlich eine Gewöhnungsphase, aber es klingt alles viel besser. Aber zu welchem Preis? Das ist wie wenn du bei dem Klavier einfach diese Dämpfungspedal loslässt und plötzlich klingt alles klar und alles gut und alles geil. Und dann denkst du dir, wow, krass. Aber dann tatsächlich gab es einen Moment auch in einem Schullager, Schularbeitslager tatsächlich, in der Kohlemine, wo ich tatsächlich mit einem befreundeten jungen Mann im Zimmer war, der auch Gitarre gespielt hat und der war halt so Hochpubertätsphase, so, wer mit wem hier und da, Lustmolch und so. Da gab es dann die Situation, dass eine... Ich glaube, deine Gags haben mir so weit die Geschichte verzerrt für mich im Kopf. Das ist einfach nur noch so eine komische homosexuelle Erfahrung. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Es war eine extrem heterosexuelle Erfahrung, weil ein anwesendes Mädchen gesagt hat, ich mag den Punkt, Punkt, Punkt nicht, der hat so ekelhaft lange Fingernägel. Sondern da dachte ich, ich als Gitarrenspieler wusste, einerseits spielst du Gitarre, um Frauen zu beeindrucken, andererseits hindert dich dein konkretes Gitarrenspiel daran, bei Frauen anzukommen, weil die es ekelhaft finden, wenn die so lange Fingernägel haben. Und wenn man jetzt den geschlechtlichen Akt weiterdenkt, kann es ja in gewisser Weise auch hinderlich sein, lange Fingernägel zu haben. Und deswegen muss man... Also du hast hergesetzt, hast nachgedacht, was mitzumachen, aber beim Nachdenken hast du deinen Kopf gekratzt, musstest aber den Arm nicht bewegen, weil deine lächerlichen Wolverine-Fingernägel einfach von Boden heraus deinen Kopf kratzen konnten. Ich habe aus dem Nebenzimmer in die Chipstüte gegriffen und es war überhaupt kein Problem. Und man muss halt dann, das ist dann wirklich so ein Gleichgewichtsspiel. Lang genug, dass man Fingernägel kann, um Frauen überhaupt ins Bett zu kriegen, aber dann nicht zu lang, dass man dann Probleme hat. Also es war, und deswegen habe ich mit Fingernägeln ein ganz eigenes Verhältnis, also nicht, dass eines dieser beiden jemals stattgefunden hätte, aber du musstest immer dir sehr gut überlegen, wie weit willst du es treiben. Das ist ganz spannend. Und tatsächlich habe ich mir dann auch irgendwann extrem feines Schleifpapier bestellt. Also das, was du im Baumarkt kaufen kannst, hat ja, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, 600 dpu, 800 dpu, das kannst du im Gitarrenhandwerk komplett brauchen. Da geht es 1500 dpu aufwärts. Ich glaube, es ist Hubbel. Hubbel pro Quadratmeter, Zentimeter. Und das wirklich so Goldschmiede benutzen, um die Ringe zu feilen oder was auch immer. Also extrem feines Schleifpapier. Das kann man benutzen, um die Fingernägel ganz glatt zu machen, weil du ja dann auf der Seite längst sozusagen an dem Giebel des Nagels entlang. Also du kratzt die Saiten nicht, sondern du streichst die senkrecht im 90-Grad-Winkel, so ein bisschen, nicht ganz 90 Grad, aber so dem Fingernagel entlang. Und deswegen müssen die natürlich, damit es nicht kratzt an der Seite, ganz smooth sein. Und das habe ich wirklich perfektioniert, die ganz smooth. Die waren auch ganz hell, die haben auch immer so ein Lichtschein geworfen und du konntest so leere auch immer damit zu blenden, weil die so ganz wie so Spiegel waren. Es war unglaublich. Widerlich, ganz, ganz ekelhaft. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das drauf kommt. Klettverschluss. Wir haben angefangen beim Klettverschluss. Und ich bin dafür, und da plädiere ich mal jetzt kurz an alle Hörer daraus, dass wir mal anfangen zusammen als Masse, wir brauchen nämlich eine Masse dafür, ich habe auch überlegt, schon mal eine Petition zu starten, einen Tag festzulegen, wo wir uns alle wieder darauf einigen, Klettverschlüsse zu benutzen bei Schuhen. Weil es ist offensichtlich besser, einfacher, es ist aber leider auch ein bisschen peinlich. Wenn ich jetzt mit anfange hier morgens, ich werde eh schon gemobbt, da probiere ich ein neues Shirt aus, probiere ich mal die Ringeloptik aus, Leute direkt, haha, machen mich fertig. Wenn ich jetzt anfange, Klettverschlüsse zu tragen, ich bin ein Trendsetter, aber so weit will ich mich nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen, wenn wir einfach alle mal als eine große Gruppe, dass es fast schon wieder eine coole Minderheit wird, anfangen, das zu tragen mit Kleppverschlüssen, glaube ich. Das Einzige, was ja ein Vollidioten von einem Trendsetter unterscheidet, ist, dass die Masse nachzieht, so dass man auf seinen Caps den Sticker da drauf lässt. Ja, und selbstbewusst sein. Dass sich das durchsetzt und dass es den Masse macht. Trottel das Vergessenheit. Es gibt ja hundert Leute, die ähnliche Dinge gemacht haben, die keine Ahnung, dann ihr Preisschild am T-Shirt gelassen haben oder die den Sticker auf der Banane gelassen haben und die Banane gegessen haben, wo man einfach sagt, Vollidiot. Aber der andere ist rückwirkend mega selbstbewusst, mega mutig, mega Trendsetter, weil er der erste war, der den Sticker auf seinem Kettel lasst.
Ich glaube, die meisten Trends werden wirklich durch Paparazzi-Fotos in die Wege geleitet. Und deswegen glaube ich, tragen mittlerweile so viele Leute Jogginghosen, weil man die Stars privat sieht und die dann oft einfach auch in so Gammelkleidung rumlaufen. Ich glaube, deswegen ist einfach irgendwann mal so die Jonghose sehr beliebt, dein Nummer eins Kleidungsmerkmal beliebt geworden, weil Leute ihre Stars, ihre Vorbilder damit assoziieren, mit Bildern.
Kurzes Blitzreferat von Stefan Tietze, wie funktioniert ein Klettverschluss?
Klepperschluss. Es sind ganz viele, ganz viele kleine Häkchen, das sind die harten Teile, sind ganz viele kleine Häkchen und dann hast du auf der anderen Seite hast du diesen Synthetikstoff, diese Plastik kleinen Fäden und dann drückst du es da drauf und dann verhakt sich das, diese kleinen Häkchen verhaken sich in der Wolle und dadurch hast du ganz viele kleine Affenärmchen, die sich festhalten und dann kannst du es auseinanderziehen und dann macht es dieses schöne Geräusch, weil die ganzen Ärmchen loslassen. Sehr gut. Ist das richtig? Ja. Das ist völlig richtig. Würdest du dich eher als eine Klettverschluss-harte-Seite-Person oder eine Klettverschluss-weiche-Seite-Person bezeichnen? Auf jeden Fall harte Seite. Ich bin auch harte Seite, glaube ich. Ich bin der, der Dinge festhält, obwohl sie schon lange weg sein sollten. Vor allem, du bist ja ein Fummler. Klar, du hast ja schon. Du bist ja jemand, der auch gerne rumfummelt. Aber wenn du jetzt so diesen Streifen, diesen Klettverschlussstreifen in der Hand hast, würdest du eher an den Weichen fummeln oder eher an den Harten fummeln? Eher an den Weichen. Die Harten sind mir so kratzbürstig. Das ist mir zu abstossend. Die Weichen, die schmeicheln eher an die Fingerkuppe. Du hast ja auch harte Fingerkuppen, du hast ja auch Bass gespielt. Ja, und dann bei Bass hast du halt das Ding, anders noch als bei der E-, A- und D-Seite auf der Gitarre, hast du da ja diese dicken Riffel. Die sind ja richtig doll gewickelt, einfach damit die sind auch krass gespannt, dass es hält. und die sind sehr stabil und deswegen bilden sich beim Drübersliden, du hast ja beim Bass auch auf dieses Duuuh, da bilden sich dann halt sehr sehr viel Hornhaut einfach um das, und da bist du auch irgendwann, du musst zwar nicht aktiv die Entscheidung treffen, jetzt quasi deine Fingernegel langzulassen oder so. Du musst einfach irgendwann, bist du vor der Frage gestellt, ob du diese Hornhaut, diese Zentimeterdicke Hornhaut an deiner linken Hand akzeptieren willst oder nicht. Aber das sieht nicht so unnatürlich aus. Also es sieht schon, deine Fingernägel wirken nur etwas wie so Hammerhaie. Aber könnte man dich noch als Bassspieler erkennen jetzt oder entwickelt sich das auch? Ich gehe sofort zurück, ja. Kannst du nicht mehr erkennen, glaube ich. Krass. Wobei ich habe vorne, siehst du das? Diesen Hubbel. Das könnte davon kommen. Oh, das sieht aber nicht schlecht aus. Das hat was Ästhetisches. Hast du das auch? Nee, ich habe wirklich ballig. Ich habe eine ganz knubbel, ganz kurze Fingernägel. Ja, ja, ich hab aber auch Knubbel. Ich bewerte oft Menschen, ich stecke in Menschen gerne Schubladen. Und Fingernägel sind so ein Faktor. Ich kann mich noch an die Fingernägellänge von manchen Mitschülerneck erinnern. Ist es gruselig? Wir sind gruselig schon. Nö, ja. Ich kann mir von einem Emre, hieß der, mit dem war ich lange befreundet. Oh ja, jeder kennt einen Emre. Und Emre hatte sehr, sehr unfassbar kurze Fingernägel, die so kurz waren, dass sie halt, bevor sie, das hast du auch so ein bisschen, bevor die wieder runtergehen, die immer so eine quasi so einen Horizont bilden, die ja so eine leichte Wölbung. Und manche haben die so kurz, dass sie nicht mehr nach unten gehen, sondern nach oben hin. Ja, wie so eine Sprungschanze, die sich dann so nach oben fettet. Und das hast du so ein bisschen. Also wenn sich das Bauchfett über die Jeans wölbt, so wölbt sich dann auch das Fingernagelbettkuppel, ich weiß es nicht genau. Ja, aber dann steht es so hoch und dann sammelt sich auch mehr direkt darunter. Warst du immer bei einer Maniküre? Nee, nie. Als ob du nicht vor dem X-Faktor-Aufgriff bei einer Maniküre warst. Nie im Leben. Gar nicht? Nee, nie im Leben. Pediküre? Nein, nie, beides nie. Kuvertüre? Overtüre war ich oft. Naja, Leute, wir hatten jetzt auch Urlaub ein bisschen. Wir sind zurückgekehrt. Ich bin noch gar nicht im Modus so. Ich bin noch völlig im Urlaubsmodus. Ich habe gemerkt, ich brauche echt lange... Du warst eine Woche lang nach New York, also da können wir auch noch ewig drüber sprechen, was in New York noch alles passiert ist. Boah, die Stadt, die nehmals schläft. Nehmals. So heiß ist es, glaube glaube ich heute morgen hat mein Wecker geklingelt und meine erste Reaktion war was für ein Folly du hat irgend so ein Depp hat seinen Klinger angelassen und ich dachte es hat eine Weile gedauert bis ich so fach das ist meiner und dann bin ich erst aufgestanden und bin aus dem Bett gewölbt hast du gesprochen in der zweiten Woche weil du redest auch so als ob du so einen Monat lang einfach mal irgendwie so im Schweigekloster in Tibet warst und nicht gesprochen hast. Und dann einfach alles neu lernen. Du stolperst noch so ein bisschen. Man muss alles neu lernen. Ich will dir so ein Dreirad an deinen Mund basteln, weil du irgendwie so Stützräder an deinen Mund bauen, weil du nicht mehr, noch nicht so richtig, eigentlich auch nicht. Ach ja, ey, du warst dann noch campen schön, ne? Boah, ich hab richtig heftig zugenommen. Hast du erzählt, du hast sechs Kilo zugenommen? Über sechs Kilo habe ich zugenommen in 15 Tagen. Boah. Habe ich zugenommen. Aber es ist ja auch so ein Dammverhalten. Es ist ja auch, wenn du lange nicht zugenommen hast und dann der Körper die Möglichkeit sieht, dann geht er all in. Das ist so Kickstart einfach so, dann geht er direkt all in. Weil ich glaube, es ist ja auch aus der menschlichen Geschichte sinnvoll, punktuell viel zunehmen. Schnell zuzunehmen. Der Mensch kommt ja von der Schlange. Und die Schlange ist ja einmal im Monat. Achtzehn Fragen haben sich gerade in den Kopf gebildet. Die Schlange ist ja einmal im Monat ein Reh, aber dafür halt gleich ein ganzes fucking Reh. Das heißt, die Schlange, hat die Schlange Fettpolster eigentlich? Du bist sehr schnell von einem Schlangexperten zu jemand, der sich einfach nur sehr deutlich für Schlangen interessiert geworden. Kann ich dir nicht beantworten. Ich glaube, es ist aber so, dass wenn du als Menschen, weil Menschen sind ja mit Mammuts groß geworden und da gab es halt einmal ein Mammut und dann mussten alle wahnsinnig viel essen und dann haben die halt ganz schnell ganz viel Fettreserven gebildet, anstatt dass der Körper sagt so, ojojojo, jetzt reicht es aber mal. Die Mammuts jetzt oder was? Ja. Und der Körper hat auch erst mal gesagt,
so Mammuts-Fragezeichen, hat sich aber relativ
schnell dran gewöhnt. Naja, ich weiß,
es wird, ich werde
wieder ein paar Jährchen brauchen, um das wieder runterzukriegen.
Ich habe ein Kilo abgenommen, wie das möglich ist.
Es ist auch langsam, mein Körper, glaube ich,
ist in so einem Joking-Modus,
in so einem Prank-Modus, weil
ich gebe mir jetzt mittlerweile seit ein paar Monaten im Fitnessstudio Mühe, besser in Form zu kommen, auch ein bisschen abzunehmen und so. Und es klappt wirklich, also ich nehme spärlich ab, ganz wenig nur, immer mal hier so ein bisschen, aber dann nehme ich auch gerne wieder was zu. Und dann eigentlich bleibe ich immer gleichmäßig, vielleicht nehme ich mal so ein Kilo in so zwei Monaten ab oder sowas. Wird sehr langsam. Und das habe ich in New York nur gefressen, wirklich widerlich gefressen, Peanut Butter
Jelly die ganze Zeit. zwei Monate ab oder sowas. Sehr langsam. Und das habe ich in New York nur gefressen,
wirklich widerlich gefressen,
Peanut Butter Jelly, die ganze Zeit
Reese's Pieces und Reese's Peanut Butter Cops die ganze Zeit gegessen,
Five Guys Burger, die ganze Zeit Five Guys Burger.
Ich hätte mir doch einen sechsten Guy hätten leisten können.
Aber es ist wirklich schlimm gegessen
und am Ende stehe ich mich auf die Waage,
ein Kilo abgenommen.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Letztes Mal habe ich in New York auch, glaube ich, sogar abgenommen oder ein bisschen weniger, aber diesmal habe ich massiv zugenommen. Ja, es ist einfach eine Lotterie. Vielleicht hat man einen Freifahrtschein oder sowas. Ich glaube auch, dass es deswegen so viele Ernährungsberater und Bücher gibt, weil man es einfach nicht weiß. Man kann da auch reinschreiben, so Leute, kein Plan, gar kein Plan. Vielleicht, aber dann auch länger, ich weiß es nicht. Logisch. Ich glaube, die meisten versuchen das mit Logik zu erklären. Es macht Sinn, dass man danach mehr isst, weil man Hunger hat. Jojo-Effekt. Das ist die einzige, gibt es eine wissenschaftliche Grundlage für den Jojo-Effekt oder es ist einfach so ein, es macht schon Sinn, dass man danach nach einer Diät ein bisschen mehr Hunger hat als sonst. Man weiss es nicht. Ist es ein psychologisches Ding, ist es ein körperliches Ding, man weiß es einfach nicht, dass es alles komplett wäre. Das ist schrecklich. Der Mensch ist zu komplex. Der Mensch ist zu komplex. Amöben haben nicht das Problem. Die sagen so, ja, ich sehe meinen Magen, ich sehe die vier Zellen, die meinen Magen ausmachen. Ich kann das alles nachvollziehen. Der Mensch ist zu komplex. Verstehst du einfach nicht mehr. Weißt du eine Qualle, wie sie aussieht? Hat noch einen Spiegel gesehen, hat nicht mehr Augen. Nee, aber sie hat nicht mehr Augen. Ja, sie sehen andere Qualen. Ja, und es können einfach, er denkt sich wie eine Wahl, die einfach andere Qualen abhängt. Er war so ein Strudel aus Qualen. Und der Wahl denkt, er sei selber eine Quale, oder was? Und alle sagen so, hey Larry, pass mal auf. Leute. Du kannst nicht ständig bei den Geburtstagen unserer Kinder dabei sein. Warum nicht? Guck mal, fällt dir was auf, wie viel Prozent der Höhle nimmst du gerade ein? Also, ich war in New York ein bisschen zugenommen, aber... Ja, aber auch sonst. Ja, schon eine Menge. Ja, eine grosse Menge. Ja, schon eine grosse Menge. Und so weiter. Und so weiter. Wenn ihr mehr von herausragenden Impro-Hörspielen haben wollt, dann fliegt nach New York und geht nach UCB. Die sind richtig gut. Ja, das muss man echt empfehlen. New York war klasse, oder? Haben wir noch was erlebt? Wir haben das YouTube-Ufo gemacht, da könnt ihr noch nachhören. Das war auch, Leute, da haben wir dann die Zugangsdaten vergessen, leider die E-Mail-Adresse vergessen. Und da mache ich hier einen Shoutout, einen negativen Shoutout. Wie heissen die, negative Shoutouts? Diss. Ein Diss geht raus an fucking YouTube und Google. Ja, du mal. Nur wenn man vergessen hat, welche E-Mail-Adressen man für seinen Account benutzt hat, sich deshalb nicht mehr einloggen zu können, ist so eine lächerliche, veraltete Steinzeit-Mechanik, ey. Wie bescheuert. Man kann auch vergessen, was man, das Passwort hätten wir vielleicht noch gewusst. Wir hätten nicht mehr die Chance, ein Passwort einzugeben, weil wir die E-Mail-Adresse nicht mehr wussten. Und dann kann man doch einfach uns mit diesem Sternchen anzeigen, was unsere E-Mail-Adresse ist. Ja, vor allem das ist halt wieder so ein Schnellschuss. Das ist wieder so ein, ah, wir legen schnell einen YouTube-Account an, wir denken uns schnell eine lustige E-Mail-Adresse an, wo dann halt wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch drei Gags drin sind, irgendwie haha, E-Mail, Postfach, E-Mail, irgendwas, at yahoo.com oder sowas, haha, lass mal eine E-Mail-Adresse bei yahoo.com machen und am Ende dann sitzen wir dann da und haben keine Ahnung mehr und bereuen unseren Gag. Das sind unsere Fingernägel. Wir müssen sich irgendwann entscheiden, sind wir bereit, unsere Fingernägel wachsen zu lassen und zu sagen, wir machen überall noch einen Gag, oder greift uns das mittlerweile so sehr ein in unserem Erfolg, dass unsere Gags mittlerweile auch Dinge kaputt machen einfach. Gags ruinieren unsere Karriere. Wir könnten jetzt einen erfolgreichen Liede-Account mit zwei, acht Abonnenten haben ungefähr.
Tatsächlich, sobald du eine eingeschweiste DVD kaufst, weißt du, du hast alles richtig gemacht als Gitarrist. Dieser Fingernagel, der einfach mal schön die Plastikfolie durchsäbelt. Nutella-Glas, super. Bist du ein Stecher oder bist du ein Reisser? Ich bin Stecher. Stecher und dann wie so ein Dosenöffner, einfach ringsrum. Ja, ich bin erstmal ein Tipper.
Ich will so dieses Tippgefühl haben.
Und dann, ah, beim Nutella-Glas gibt es das große Problem, du hast nämlich immer an einer Stelle ein bisschen Nutella obendrum.
Ja, warum?
Es gibt immer, weil, Abfüllen, ich vermute das Abfüllen, ich vermute das Abfüllprocedere, wo einmal, wenn es noch im flüssigeren Zustand ist, weil es muss ja auch reingeschossen werden, dieses Produkt ist also ein bisschen flüssiger noch. Und dann muss es irgendwann mal beim Zuschweissen oder so einen so einen Ruck geben. Nee, wenn du das da einfüllst, dann zieht es doch so nach und dann hast du so einen kleinen Berg oben. Ja, aber das Problem ist ja... Und dann hauen die da gleich die Kappe drauf. Entweder das oder es gibt halt ... Ja, genau, wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwas beim Abfüllen, was so einen kleinen Berg verursacht, der sich aber absenkt. Aber trotzdem bleibt oben dran... Du glaubst allen Ernstes, dass dieses perfekt durchdesignte Fabrik, dass die so eine Laufbahn entlanglaufen und dann gibt es noch wie bei Tony Hawk so eine Sprungschanze, wo alle so... Und eine so kleine... Da ist eine Bodenwelle, da war ein Baum, da war so ein Mammutbaum, den wollten die nicht abreißen.
Wir würden hier gerne eine Nutella-Fabrik reinbauen. Wäre es okay, wenn wir diese Bodenwelle erstmal rausnehmen? Nein! Erstmal sehe ich sie nicht hier in der Fabrik bauen. Das ist ein Naturschutzgebiet, okay? Sie können nicht einfach Fabriken bauen, wie sie wollen. Hier steht ein Mammutbaum, der ist älter als Sie, der ist älter als ich, der ist älter als wir beide zusammen und der bleibt hier drin. Wir bauen die Fabrik über den Mammutbaum drüber.
Aha.
So, überhaupt kein Problem.
Der kann weiter leben. Der ist älter als ich, der ist älter als wir beide zusammen und der bleibt hier drin. Wir bauen die Fabrik über den Mammutbaum drüber.
Aha.
So, überhaupt kein Problem.
Der kann weiterleben, der kann machen, der kann da sein Mammutding machen.
Übrigens, ganz wichtig, früher als es noch Mammuts gart, haben Menschen tatsächlich sehr viele Fettreserven bekommen, indem sie ganz viel Mammutfleisch gegessen haben.
Ich merke, sie haben viel Mammutwissen und wenn ich einem meinem Mammutbaum anvertraue und dieses Stück Naturschutzgebiet.
Aber versprechen Sie mir, diese eine Welle bleibt drin.
Die bleibt auf jeden Fall drin.
Und so entsteht das.
Also jedes Mal, wenn ihr Nutella aufmacht.
Ich bin ein Tipper.
Und vor allem dieses Material, das ist ja einzigartig.
Also das ist ja für mich
eins über
Banknoten mit irgendeiner
Imprägnierung, die dann irgendwie so in den Lichtscheinen schimmert oder so, dass es halt wirklich eine echte Banknote ist. Eins drüber ist noch diese, also ich glaube, das zu fälschungssicher, das zu fälschen, das ist die Herausforderung. Ich glaube, auch bei dem neuen Euro-Schein hatten die gedacht, machen wir jetzt so Nutella-Etiketten, nehmen wir jetzt dieses Material von Etiketten und bleiben wir beim Alten. Und dann hat irgendein so ein konservatives Arschloch gesagt, wir bleiben beim Alten.
Ich glaube, dass auch so Geldfälscherbanden wirklich lange überlegen, ob sie entweder 50-Euro-Scheine oder diese Nutella-Papierchen fälschen sollen.
Und am Ende gesagt, dann ist es zu schwer.
Oder iTunes-Gutscheincodes.
Ich habe letztens so ein Interview gesehen mit einem Geldfälscher.
Da gibt es einen YouTube-Kanal, der so Verbrecher interviewt.
Warum hast du gezögert, als ob du interviewt worden wärst? Wo die Verbrecher so erzählen, warum sie was gemacht haben. Und da war ein Geldfälscher, der war halt echt ein mega sympathischer Typ, der halt einfach meinte, er wäre Geldfälscher gewesen, dann erwischt worden, hat er gesagt, okay, mach ich nicht mehr, sorry, sorry, sorry. Und so, und dann hat er aber wirklich sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry gesagt. Sorry, ich habe ja drei Kinder umgebracht, aber sorry, sorry, ich glaube, es ist okay. Und der Richter meinte auch, Sie haben sorry, sorry, sorry, gesagt, das tut Ihnen richtig leid. Freispruch! Ich glaube, er hat gesagt, sorry, sorry, sorry, euer Ehren. Und dann war auch alles in Ordnung. Und der hat halt gesagt, irgendwann hat er die Idee, wie man Banknoten richtig gut fälschen konnte. Weil er hat dann zwei so Drucktechniken kombiniert und kam auf die Idee und dachte sich, nee, ich mache das nicht mehr, mache nicht mehr. Aber der sass jahrelang auf diesem Wissen, das sonst niemand hatte. Niemand in der Geldfälscherszene ist auf die Idee gekommen, diese beiden Druckmechanismen zu kombinieren. Und irgendwann kam halt dann irgend so ein Krimineller, der meinte so, hey, du hast doch mal, willst du nicht? Und dann hat er gesagt, fuck it, ich mache es nochmal, ich druck nochmal Geld. Und einfach nur, um zu sehen, ob ich es kann. Und er konnte es, zack, der war irgendwie Undercover-Agent von der Polizei, der Typ, zack, hochgenommen, Gefängnis done. Ich dachte ganz, was eine coole Filmprämisse, wenn die nicht sofort wieder vorbei gewesen wäre. Wenn du sowas wie Orange is in the Black machen willst, wenn die Geschichte im Gefängnis stattfindet, dann sind das so die ersten drei Minuten. Aber das ist schon so, weil natürlich hätte der sich auch Chili-Kochen aussuchen können als seine Leidenschaft und dann das perfektionieren können. Aber er war halt einfach Geldfälscher, er war halt einfach so Druckertyp, den das halt gereizt hat. Und da kann man schon sagen, ist das immer moralisch verwerflich? Klar, er hat es ja auch einfach im Privaten machen können und halt einfach 60-Euro-Scheine drucken können mit dieser Technik und dann singen können. Der Vater von meinem damaligen besten Schulfreund in der Grundschule war Drucker. Und ich dachte immer, und deren Slogan hätte so ein Kastenwagen und auf dem stand einfach drauf, wir drucken alles außer Geld. Fand ich clever, dachte mir aber, genau das würden Geldfälscher sein. Euer Ehren, wir drucken alles euer Geld, euer Ehren. Genau dieses Logo hätten Geldfälscher. Und immer wenn er dann irgendwie, wenn wir dann zum Kiosk gegangen sind und eine gemischte Tüte mit einem Zwanni, die man halt so hat als Grundschüler gekauft, dachte ich mir so, hm, wir fliegen gleich sowas von auf, das ist kein echtes Geld. Aber dann habe ich halt gesehen, was er eigentlich gedruckt hat, er war nämlich nicht so ein richtig guter Drucker und hat dann immer nur diese Ü30-Party-Drucker äh, Ü30-Plakate gedruckt. Und kennt ihr die? Ich weiß nicht, ob die bei dir in der Stadt zum Beispiel so ähnlich waren, aber bei uns hingen die wirklich überall. Die waren einfach neon-orange mit schwarzer Druck und da standen einfach ganz groß Ü30 und dann einfach die wichtigsten Informationen. Kein Gag, keine Information zu viel, Stadthalle kamen. Ü30, wir sind verzweifelt, wir wollen es noch mal wissen, wir kriegen wahrscheinlich keinen mehr ab und viel Spaß. Genau, nee, ich war einfach ganz pragmatisch, war das sind die Facts, da müsst ihr sein, das ist es, das sind die Hard Facts, bitte. Und kein Bild oder so, einfach neon orange oder neongrün, das waren die beiden Sachen, die er gedruckt hat. Also dachte ich mir, kein Geld. Das war wahrscheinlich so wie die Kammerjäger, die sagen, wir töten alles ausser Menschen. Wo man auch sagt so, hm, wirklich? Warum sagt ihr das? Warum sprecht ihr das an explizit? Das macht nicht so viel Sinn. Ich hatte mal Angst als Kind, als meine Eltern weggegangen sind und dann haben die so als Beruhigung gesagt, guck mal, weil wir waren in so einer Siedlung, so eine Strasse, die in der Sackgasse geendet hat und dann so eine Siedlung.
Da habe ich auch gewonnen.
So mit so einem Rondell am Ende sogar.
Exakt, da habe ich auch gewonnen.
Ich habe auch an einem Kreis.
Stefan Tietze?
Wie, du bist auch Stefan Tietze?
What?
Sorry.
Yes, and.
Und ich wollte in die andere Richtung.
Wir haben ja in New York richtig gute Impro gesehen und wir haben ein ein paar Regeln mitgenommen. Und Yes, And ist natürlich die bekannteste Regel. Dass du gerade gesagt hast, nein, ich wollte in eine andere Richtung. Quasi direkt die Wand durchbrochen hast. Straight. So werden auch die meisten Impro-Szenen beendet mit, ja sorry, ich wollte eigentlich, dass er jetzt auf Obama anspricht. Egal. Da bin ich mal so meine eltern wie gegangen und dann habe ich gesagt
strahle und dann hat meine mutter so gesagt nein du musst dich hier keine sorgen machen guck mal hier alle wohnen guck mal hier der der nachbar der steppenreiter der ist polizist und der herr lorenz das ist ein arzt und der der herr frödler der vater von meinem besten freund Der spielt Saxophon in einer Band.
Also, dir geht es dir gut.
Ich dachte mir da schon so, okay, okay, okay, gut, ihr habt es verstanden. Das ist mein Schicksal hier. Ich habe keine Angst, Polizist, Arzt und Saxophonspieler, alles da. Also da ist mir auf jeden Fall geholfen. Aber wenn dann was passiert wäre, wäre wahrscheinlich der Saxophonspieler gekommen und hätte mich gerettet. Ich glaube auch, das wollte ich gerade sagen, wahrscheinlich wäre das dann der Typ gewesen, der die krassen... Oh nein, er kommt auf! Detektiv Conan, die ganze Zeit Detektiv Conan. Sexman, war das eigentlich ein... War das ein Vergewaltiger oder ein Superman? Die Epic-Saxman. Sexman, no, Saxophone. Ladies, come back, ladies, stop running, stop running, officer, put the gun down! Put the gun down! Epic Sex Guy. I'm a sex man. Sex Guy! Ich hab mal ... Ganz kurz, Sex on the beach ist schon ... Sex. Saxophon. Also Sex. Nein, nein, Saxophon auf dem Strand. Ich wirklich ... Ich lüge dich nicht an, wenn ich sage, dass ich gerade wirklich nicht weiß, ob es Sex oder Sex ist.
Sex on the Beach. Ficken am Strand. Ficken am Strand ist die Übersetzung von diesem Drink.
Sex on the Beach. Ja. Weißt du ja auch nicht, was die erste Mal so zu kommen.
Sex on the City and the Beach.
Ich hatte auch mal Angst, das ist glaube ich auch so eine Phase, die man durchmacht, wenn die Eltern einen erst mal alleine lassen, hat man immer Angst, dass sie nicht mehr zurückkommen.
Unbegründet. Und dann hatte ich wirklich Angst, dass sie nicht zurückkommen und habe dann quasi mich mit dem Gedanken zu trösten, dass sie auf jeden Fall zurückkommen müssen, habe ich einen Zettel geschrieben. Hallo Mama und Papa, ich freue mich, dass ihr wieder da seid. Ich habe die ganze Zeit auf euch gewartet und hatte keine Angst, Stefan. Einen Zettel habe ich geschrieben und außen an die Tür geklebt, damit alle sehen, dass gerade niemand zu Hause ist, ein zweijähriger Junge alleine irgendwo, der gerade so schreiben kann. Ein zweijähriger, schreibfähiger Junge, extrem schlaues Kind, alleine ist und offensichtlich auch die dümmste Idee. Also für jemanden, der will, dass einem gerade nichts passiert, ist es dumm, etwas von außen in die Tür zu kleben. Naja. Hattest du das mal erfahren mit Einbruch? Nee, es wurde mal neben uns, neben einem wurde mal eingebrochen. Und wir hatten immer, was ich das Schlauste der Welt fand, wir hatten so eine Fake-Alarmanlage. Wir hatten immer, und zwar kennt man ja, ich glaube, das war ganz billig, ein billiger Trick von meinem Vater, der einfach irgendwann diese, kann man diese Fake-Blaulichter kaufen, die man auch, die man so, Spielzeug, für kleine Spielzeugautos, und das Ganze war auch in Rot, so wie halt Alarmanlagen so vor 20.000 Jahren aussahen, die erste Alarmanlage, so große Rot-Rotoren, ausser sieh keine Alarmanlage zu Hause aus, hat das genommen und so sichtbar, wenn man vor der Tür steht und sich so ein bisschen umguckt, würde man genau dieses Ding sehen. Das ist ja aber eine gute Idee. Und das ist natürlich nie angeschlossen und so und hat auch nicht funktioniert, aber das hängen wir uns immer dran. Das hat niemand Angst bei uns vor. Das ist ja genial, Wie auch viele von so Überwachungskameras gar nicht laufen und verkabelt sind, sondern so
Attrappen sind. Aber die, die dich verfolgen,
die dich sehen. Genau, vor allem die.
Aber weil du dann nicht halt anders
verhältst, wenn du weißt, dass überall Kameras sind.
Ja. Wie verhältst du dich dann?
Ich tanze,
ich singe mein Lied,
ich präsentiere mich.
Ich möchte auch ein bisschen. Ich ziehe mir mein Shirt aus erst, dann fange ich an zu jonglieren. Das Lustigste, was mir gerade eingefallen ist. Ich bin noch ein bisschen in so einem Ruhemodus, weißt du, dieser Mondmodus. Mondmodus ist mein Modus, wirklich. Wusstet ihr, dass der Mondmodus überlistet werden kann bei dringenden Anrufen? Ja. Ihr müsst jemanden, wenn ihr merkt, man geht direkt auf die Mailbox. Nee, das klingt, glaube ich, ein... Also, da kann man jedenfalls beim Anrufen schon merken, ob der andere im Mondmodus ist. Da muss man einfach normal anrufen, direkt, und dann wird man durchgestellt. Außer du hast auch das ausgestellt. Und das hast du natürlich gemacht. Natürlich. Weil dich aber auch niemand anruft. Kein Bock auf Notfälle. Niemand ruft dich an. Ich habe gerade auf Notfälle kein Bock. deswegen gerade die rausfiltern bitte. Oh, ich liebe Notfälle. Hast du schon mal die Notruf gewählt? Ja, und zwar berühmte Tequila Ladies Night. Es war eine Vorfinanzierungsfeier für unser Abitur. Wir haben ja bestimmt auch gehabt, Fofis, sogenannte Fofis. Vorfinanzierungsfäden, einfach Fofifes müssen die heißen, wo man halt dann lernt, wo man dann Geld verdient, um seine Abiturfeier zu lernen. Und dort hatten wir mal den Tequila-Abend. Und aus irgendeinem Grund fanden es alle an dem Abend lustig, mir Tequila auszugeben. Und das war eine einzige Trink-Story, die ich habe. Es ist nicht meine Story, es ist einfach ein komplettes Shutdown, wo auch so Lehrer zu mir kamen, die zu sagen, trinke einen mit mir, die bestimmt verarscht haben, die dann so weggekippt haben und mich trinken lassen haben. Tausende Menschen sind zu mir gekommen, ich musste ein Tiki da trinken, nach Minute zehn auf dieser Party, ich war gerade angekommen, es war acht Uhr oder so, zehn nach acht, ich weiß gar nichts mehr, was los war. Aber bin am nächsten Tag aufgewacht, habe einfach so einen grossen roten Strich auf meiner Stirn, einfach so einen senkrechten Strich auf meiner Stirn. Und hat sich nachher herausgestellt, dass ich dann wirklich, ich bin reingekommen, war auch einer der Ersten, der da war, direkt wieder raus. Noch bevor du die Jacke aufgehängt hast, lagst du am Boden. Hab meine Jacke abgegeben, rein, dann zehn Minuten später wieder raus, also wenn man die Überwachungskamera sehe, lächerlich, komm wieder raus, nimm meine Jacke, bedank mich noch beim Kumpel, der Jacke gegeben hat, der sich gefordert hat, was ist mit ihm jetzt schon los, lauf gegen eine Tür, die direkt hinter mir steht, krieg den roten Strich und dann erinnere ich mich noch schämenhaft an Dinge, die dann passiert sind. Unter anderem, erinnere mich nicht mehr daran, aber mein Handy beweist es, habe ich den Notruf gewählt dann. Eins, eins, zwei und habe zwölf Sekunden lang mit dem Notruf telefoniert, dann aufgelegt und dann bin ich im Taxi nach Hause gefahren und bin dann im Taxi eingeschlafen und der Taxifahrer hat mich vor meiner Haustür wieder geweckt und dann war ich zu Hause. Das war Tequila, Tequila Night mit dem Tizze, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii, Eii Versehen bei einem Notruf angerufen, weil ich erst kürzlich bei einem Dreh sollte ich halt so tun, als würde ich eine App bedienen.
Und ich hatte das Handy von unserem Kameraassistenten und habe dann halt einfach so wild rumgetippt und habe dann tatsächlich gemerkt, oh fuck, 110 und der ruft ja auch sofort an. Nee, stimmt nicht. Ich hab in dem Lockscreen ...
Kannst du automatisch auf Nothof gehen?
Da hab ich draufgedrückt und hab dann versucht, die Szene weiterzuspielen.
Ich dachte mir, jetzt ist ist Spiel mit dem Feuer. Und dann hab ich aufgelegt, dann bin ich die Szene abgemacht. Aber das war eine der schlimmsten Entscheidungen meines jungen Lebens. Manchmal, also du bist ja auch da ein Comedy-Fox, ne? Ja. Und du weißt ja, dir kann ja nicht, wie viel passieren, außer ein gehöriges Bußgeld. Ja, nee, damit macht man keine Gags. Nee, ne? Das finde ich eine richtige Erwachsene Einstellung. Es ist tatsächlich so, also man sieht sich ja konfrontiert mit diesem davon über alles Gags machen und so und ja, aber das sind so echt so Sachen, ich glaube, das kann man trennen von inhaltlich Gags machen, einfach so was, was sich nicht überschreiten würde. Ich würde nicht aus Spaß Notruf anrufen oder sowas. Aber das ist, glaube ich, eher eine formelle Sache als eine inhaltliche Sache. Inhaltlich würde ich schon sagen, man kann über alles Gags machen, aber das geht ja dann in die Prank. Ne, es geht vor allem nicht in die Prank, es geht vor allem in die, du verletzt andere Menschen. Also teilweise auch, du könntest durch diese Aktion physisch anderen Schaden zufügen. Wenn die dann niemanden erreichen da. Wenn die verhaftet werden dann einfach so. Wenn die dann mit der Verhaftung von Florentin Will beschäftigt sind, der sich dann um sich trampelt, ich lasse mich nicht so schnell verhaften, der sich um sich trampelt, anfängt und dann auf seinem kleinen Elektroroller losfällt. Das könnte ich aber versuchen, mich zu verhaften. Du wirst dich entschuldigen, du wirst dich auf die Knie werfen, dich sofort ergeben. Sofort. Sofort. Ach ja. Was machst du gerade so? Ich habe neulich angefangen, ich habe mal wieder angefangen, Fernsehen zu gucken, weil mir wurde das Internet abgestellt, zu Hause, komplett. Ich habe kein Internet mehr, danke, Deutsche Telekom. Ich habe wirklich jetzt für zwei Wochen kein Internet und habe angefangen, wieder Fernsehen zu gucken. Und es sind so weirde, weirde, weirde Sachen, die da passieren. Und ich wusste bis vor dem Tag noch nicht, dass Gold immer noch ein Ding ist. Es gibt immer noch Goldgräber und Goldsammler. Und dann gibt es, und zwar in der Beringsee, ich glaube, das ist zwischen Amerika und England und so, da sucht man, weiß ich jetzt, ich sag gar nicht, wo die Beringsee ist, ein Meer, ein Meeresabschnitt,
und da suchen
Leute noch nach Gold, und dann
tauchen die nach Gold, und dann
war das eine Sendung auf D-Max oder so,
oder auf RTL2, und
die haben sich nur damit beschäftigt,
dass Leute, dass verschiedene Teams
nach Gold, nach Gold graben,
und da waren so illustre Charaktere, also
ist das noch ein Thema, wusstest du, dass Gold noch ein Thema ist? Ich dachte nicht, nee. Aber die suchen, die graben dann noch, die fahren dann auf die See, haben dann so Metalldetektoren und sind einfach so wahnsinnig, ist ein bisschen wie so Waterworld. Moment, aber die müssen doch da wahnsinnig tief tauchen, oder? Ja, die tauchen wahnsinnig tief, ist das auch gefährlich. Du kannst ja nicht an den Boden des Meeres tauchen. Naja, ich glaube, an manchen Stellen vor der Küste, wo es ein bisschen flacher ist vielleicht, wo dann auch mal so Goldlaster verunglückt sind, richtig berühmte Goldschiffe. Und dann haben die halt so wahnsinnig aufgebaute, mit so grossen Röhren und Schläuchen versehene Schiffe, die so sehr zweckmäßig sind, weil die alle kein Geld haben, weil die sind alle sehr arme Schlucker, deswegen suchen die ja nach Gold. und haben dann so ganz zweckmännische Geschiffe, mit denen die dann da rumfahren und die auch kaum fahren können.
Und dann in diese furchtbaren Situationen kommen und es ist einfach so eine Talking-Head-Leute, halt eine Kamera drauf, Serie, also die Sätze empfehlen, mit sehr illustren Charakteren, die die ganze Zeit unfassbar Energie haben und die ganze Zeit so eine Hey, I'm James Amfield, this is my boat, the air mares Dumphy, wow, like my aunt, Mrs. Dumphy. Have you found anything? Never, never found anything. Und die haben immer so eine, die holen immer so aus und die haben so eine Energie und so eine Inbrunst, das ist Wahnsinn. Guckt euch diese Serie an, ey Wahnsinn. Und dann fahren die da einfach rum und verunglücken und tatsächlich denkt man, wow, dieser Tauchvorgang muss ja schon sehr gefährlich sein, weil die ja sehr tief tauchen und dann nach Graben und auch dann teilweise in scharfen, mit scharfen Rändern, so scharfen Schiffwracks rumkramen und die auch dann den Tauchanzug beschädigen können und so. Tatsächlich hat sich einer dann verletzt, auch während ich zugeschaut habe, die ganzen fünf Minuten, hat sich so weiter verletzt und zwar, weil der betrunken einem, den Freunden hinterher geschwommen ist, die sie schon abgelegt haben. Das ist dann wohl die Nummer eins Gefahrenquelle, Dummheit bei diesen Goldtauchern. Krass, nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, das hat schon was sehr Romantisches, dieses Sachen, Suchen. Mega. Ich glaube, Suchen ist auch so was Urmenschliches, was eine ganz tiefe innere Befriedigung gibt. Ja, aber Suchen mit dem Wissen, man findet es auch. Also man kann es auch finden. Ich finde, als ich mal als Kind gehört, man hat immer so Begeisterungsfaden, so Piraten fand ich mal toll. Mit Freunden hat man dann auch so Schatzkarten gemalt und so. Man wusste, das ist alles Fiktion. Aber als man irgendwann gehört hat, es liegen wirklich noch irgendwo Schätze vergraben, weil es liegt ja immer noch irgendwo, es liegen noch Schätze vergraben, von denen man sich erzählt, auch aus dem NSDAP-Bereich. Aber mit dem Wissen ist es doch total geil. Also erweckt das so eine Lust, ihm wieder nachzusuchen. Ja. Wollen wir mal irgendwas suchen? Wollen wir mal irgendwie so einen Schatz suchen von Nazis? Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold. Das ist ein Goldzug, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, Gold, viel Gutes und da ja auch Operationen Barbarossa geplant haben und so, also riesige Sachen und wo Hitler auch oft unterwegs war. Und da war es dann so, als die Amerikaner dann kamen und dann das irgendwie befreit haben und dann sind die ganzen Nazis abgehauen, da gab es dann auch noch so einen großen Kunstraubzug, also einen Zug, also einen Train, also kein Raubzug, sondern einen tatsächlichen Tutut, Tuff-Tuff-Zug. Also schon so ein Zug, wie man sich so figurativen Zug. Genau, genau, genau. Und den gab es und da hat Göring versucht, seine ganzen Kunstschätze rauszubringen. Seine Bilder hat er gemalt.
Und dann kam es aber so, dass es irgendwie Komplikationen gab, weil die Amerikaner kamen. Und dann kam Berthesgadener und haben den geplündert, diesen Zug. Die sind dann auf die Gleise gesprungen und haben den einfach geplündert und haben dann da einfach unglaubliche Kunstschätze entwendet und haben die dann einfach bei sich zu Hause versteckt. Das heisst, in Berthesgaden gibt es noch in irgendwelchen Kellern irgendwie ein Rembrandt oder ein Monet oder wirklich krass wahnsinnig wertvolle krasse Gemälde und Kunstwerke, die man einfach nicht mehr findet. Du kannst jetzt nicht einfach sagen, okay, wir durchsuchen jetzt jedes Haus da. Die sind weg. Aber irgendwann erbt einfach irgend so ein Typ so, ah ja, übrigens, wir haben dann noch ein Picasso im Keller. Und du so, what the fuck? Ciao! Und vor allem, die Frage, ob du die verkaufen kannst, weil das ist ja unendlich viel wert, da hast du ja ausgesorgt, wenn du so ein Picasso verkaufst. Wo haben sie ihn her? Geerbt von den Rembrandt, von meinem Onkel. Aber da kann man eigentlich Sachen einfach so finden? Ja, man kann Sachen einfach so finden. Das Ding ist, es gibt diese tolle Geschichte. Danke. Dass du mich ernst nimmst. Ja, ich wollte was erzählen. Als Mensch und als Freund. Ich wollte was erzählen und wusste nicht, wie ich jetzt dein schnabberndes Mundloch zum Schweigen bringen kann. Naja, es gibt diese tolle Geschichte von Wolfgang Beltracchi, dem grossartigsten Kunstfälscher der Welt, der ist einfach so ein Kölner, der die ganze Zeit einfach so rumkölnert und man denkt einfach, netter Kerl, aber der ist einfach so ein sympathischer Typ, der ist einfach der begabtestste Kunstfälscher der Welt, der noch irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren ist er in den Knast gekommen und wurde dann auch erwischt. Da gibt es eine tolle Doku, eben zu empfehlen, die Kunst der Fälschung über ihn. Und der hat mit seiner Frau solche Leute erfunden, die plötzlich nach vorne kommen und behaupten, sie hätten Kunstwerke geerbt oder sie hätten ein altes Haus ausgemistet von ihren Urahnen und da sind sie plötzlich auf Werke gestossen, weil er hat nämlich nicht bestehende Werke gefälscht, sondern er hat in die Kunstwerke reingeschrieben, die es gibt, von denen man behauptet, dass es sie gibt, oder wo es Aufzeichnungen von gab, Vorskizzen und dann hat er auch so einen berühmten Franz Mark, den es angeblich gab, einfach nachgezeichnet, wie er sich den vorgestellt hat. Dann hat er die Künstler interpretiert, aber hat seine eigenen Bilder gemalt. Es waren immer eigene Bilder, immer eigene Motive und hat die dann für sehr viel Geld an krasse Museen verkauft und so. Und ich glaube, wir waren ja jetzt in sehr vielen Museen noch in New York. Ja, mit Sicherheit, sagt man sich, hängen da noch hunderte Bilder von Wolfgang Beltracki in Museen.
Weil er hat dann immer mit seiner Frau Familien erfunden, die dann plötzlich behaupten, sie hätten Bilder. Das ist schon genial. Aber warum kann man nicht Sachen finden? Ich dachte mir zum Beispiel, als ich das erste Mal im Alter von acht Jahren von Geld Wäsche gehört habe, dachte ich mir, genial, geniales Konzept. Sauberes Geld, genial. Illegales Geld kannst du dann ausgeben für Sachen, wie du willst. Aber ich dachte mir, warum nutzt man nicht immer einfach das
Finden, dass du sagst, hey, ich habe
im Wald eine Tasche mit
10.000 Euro gefunden, die gebe ich beim
Fundamt ab und sag sorry
und nach der Zeit, wenn die niemand
will, kriegt man die ja zurück.
Wenn die niemand will, dann
wäre mein kleiner Trick,
ein paar Mal zum Fundamt zu gehen und zu sagen, oh, ich habe 10.000 Euro in der schwarzen Tasche verloren. Ja, aber dann tust du in die Tasche dann noch irgendwie einen Rubik's Cube rein und da du dann nicht sagen kannst, dass da noch ein Rubik's Cube drin ist, kriegst du das Geld. Ich habe dann gesagt, ich habe dir jemanden reingemacht. Wir können das Spiel weitertreiben, wir können das Spiel weitertreiben. Wie sieht die Tasche denn aus? Schwarz. Nee, gelb. Mit so Riemen. Nee, ohne Riemen. Die meisten haben, aber du kannst doch doch statistisch vorgehen. Die meisten Taschen sind schwarze Riemen. Ich als Geldwäscher nehme doch extra eine Tasche, die nicht jeder nimmt. Gut, auch das kannst du natürlich wieder callen und dann wird es interessant. Jetzt haben wir eine Serie. Jetzt haben wir eine Serie zwischen dem Typen, der immer Sachen im Wald findet und dem Typen, der sie immer haben will. Das ist die spannendste zwanzigteilige Serie, die YouTube-Deutschland je gesehen hat. Ja, aber das ist jetzt wirklich interessant. Und dann, kann man das behaupten? Ja. Ich glaube, es gibt genug Leute, die einfach mal so oft doof zum Fundamt gehen und sagen, die Mona Lisa habe ich letztens liegen lassen am Bahnhof. Geldwäsche ist doch, du willst es nicht versteuern. Du willst illegales Geld zu legalem Geld machen. Nee, du willst es einfach haben. Ja, du willst es haben, illegalerweise besitzen. Ja. Du kannst ja einfach Geld verdienen auch. Ja, aber wenn du jetzt einen Lamborghini kaufst, so zwei Millionen, dann sagt der Lamborghini Verkäufer, wo haben wir das Geld denn her? Das ist doch scheißegal, das geht überhaupt nichts an. Das ist Hass. Ja, aber dann sagt irgendjemand, dass der mit... Geldwäsche ist doch vor allem steuerlich. Ich dachte, es geht darum, dass Leute, die große Dinge verkaufen, nachfragen, wo haben sie das her. Nein, das Finanzamt muss Bescheid wissen. Aber wundert sich die Bank nicht irgendwann, wenn plötzlich ganz viel Geld reinkommt? Dann sagt die Bank Leute. Sie haben gesagt, vielen Dank erst mal. Erst mal per se schon mal vielen Dank. Es ist nicht mehr 2009, die Banken sind nicht mehr so korrupt, dass du jetzt diese alten Scheiss-Klischees aufrollen musst. Gott, gib mir das auf die Nerven. Du mit deinem Scheiss-Antikapital. Nein, mit meinem Tesla-Aktien-Erfahrung. Ja, voll. Ich weiss doch, was da gerade am Finanzmarkt los ist. Ja, ja, ja. Du Insektenstich übersät auch. Ja, es ist wirklich furcht. Du hast gerade gerade wirklich Gedankengänge unterbrochen, weil du dich jucken musstest. Ist es ein Problem beim Campen? Immer noch, ne? Ist es tatsächlich, ja. Ich dachte auch, das wäre so ein Problem, was ich 2009 gelöst hätte, aber nein. Tatsächlich, was sich durchgezogen hat durch das Campen und wofür ich sehr ausgelacht wurde, ist, dass ich davon ausgegangen bin, dass Fliegen Menschen stechen. Fliegen? Und Blut saugen. Fliegen? Ja? Normale Stubfliegen? Nein. Dachte ich, dass sie das tun. Warum kommt so ein Blieb an? Und alle haben laut gelacht und ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. Das war ein, ein, ein, ein, ja, ein Gejauchze ist da ausgebrochen, also da quill es aus den Leuten hervor, der Ulk tropfte zwischen den Zähnen hervor, es war grausig anzusehen, was sich da abgespielt hat. Ich dachte tatsächlich, dass Fliegen stechen. Aber warum verjagt man dann Fliegen? Dann ist doch scheißegal, dann können die ja machen, was sie wollen. Weil die unfassbar, also unfassbar nervig sind. Das hat man auch gesehen. Du bist auch so jemand, der Fliegen aber auch magisch anzieht. Danke. Acker Arsch stinkt. In New York war es so, wir lagen alle abends noch bei Florian im Bett, weil wir uns noch Geschichte über unsere Jugend erzählt haben. Wir haben die Taschenlampe ins Gesicht gehalten und gruselige Geschichten erzählt. Und wir haben uns noch mal ein bisschen auch privat sind wir geworden. Wir haben ein bisschen über Stefans Liebesleben gesprochen. Private Sachen gesprochen, ein bisschen über Liebesleben gesprochen. Und da fiel es auf, dass Fliegen, dass du immer so ein, wie ein toter Mensch, immer quasi so ein Schwarm Fliegen den Kopf herum hattest. Und da habe ich mich auch gefragt, woran das liegt. Und deswegen machst du vielleicht in der Kindheit immer etwas Schlimmeres damit verbunden, als es eigentlich da war, weil die machen nichts. Die sind nur nervig. Deswegen verjagt man sie. Habe ich mal von einer Fliegenklatsche erzählt, die ich besitze, wo ein Loch drin ist, wo drum steht, letzte Chance. Der letzte Ausweg. Das ist grausig. Das ist genial. Ich habe auch lange eine Fliegenklatsche mit Strom besessen. Ja, die hatten wir auch beim Campen. Boah, aber die tun richtig weh, die Dinger. Die tun richtig weh. Habe ich mir nie getraut, das bei mir zu machen. Doch, ich dachte, um so eine Fliege zu kremen, brauchst du was weiß ich wie viel Milliampere Stunden, keine Ahnung. Und dann lang ich da rein und du kriegst ja einen richtigen Schlag, ey, richtig hart. Können wir mal kurz über Einheiten sprechen? Oder über Milliampere Stunden zum Beispiel? Pascal pro Minute? Ja, wie kommt das da Stunden rein jetzt, weil es pro Stunde ist? Milliampere pro Stunde? Also wenn du zum Beispiel einen Akku hast, dann hat der eine gewisse Stärke pro Stunde.
Warum kann man nicht für die Stärke eine Einheit festlegen und die Stunden erstmal komplett ignorieren?
Ja, weil du ja wissen willst, wie lange es ist.
Du kannst ja ganz kurz, ganz effektiv, ganz hart sein, ganz stark für kurze Zeit, aber auf lange Sicht schwach.
Warum hat man für Geschwindigkeiten keine Einheiten mehr?
Also kmh ist keine Einheit, das ist eine Mischung aus Zeit und Strecke. Knoten. Ja, das finde ich clever. Aber bei kmh denkt man sich immer, boah, ich finde, kmh kann man sich so gut vorstellen. Wie viel bist du gefahren? Ja, 12 kmh. Dann denkst du, oh, du kannst es sehr gut vorstellen. Mach mal mit der Hand, wie du denkst, wie schnell 12 Keimhafen. Das ist ja wohl lächerlich. Mach mal! Das sind locker 30 Keimhafen. Was? Ich bin ganz langsam gefahren. Nein, das war... Gab es das eigentlich mal bei Schlag den Rabspiel, Geschwindigkeiten schätzen? Die mussten mal eine Geschwindigkeit genau treffen. Die hatten Blitzer aufgebaut und die mussten Geschwindigkeiten genau treffen mit Autofahren.
Ja, aber wenn du beschleunigst, dann gehst du ja automatisch irgendwann durch diese Geschwindigkeit durch.
Nee, die mussten ab da, wo der Blitzer steht, die Geschwindigkeit haben.
Und die dürfen danach nicht mehr beschleunigen?
Was? Nein, ab dem Punkt, wo sie geblitzt wurden, mussten sie eine Geschwindigkeit haben.
Danach konnten sie machen, was sie wollen.
Ah, so, die nur halten.
Nach Hause fahren.
Ach, sie mussten sie nicht treffen, sondern nur halten.
Nein, sie mussten die Geschwindigkeit, an dem Moment, wo sie geblitzt wurden, mussten sie die Geschwindigkeit haben, die von ihnen verlangt wurde. Hast du schon mal, wo ist jemand geblitzt? Ja. Da kriegst du doch einen Zettel, da steht eine Geschwindigkeit drauf. Ja. Da steht keine Zeitraum. Moment, also die haben jetzt vorgegeben bekommen. Danach haben sie aber beschleunigt, das hat uns aber nicht gefallen. Moment. Da steht, sie sind 28 gefahren, erlaubt waren sieben. Also die Geschwindigkeit oder drüber, oder genau treffen. Genau treffen! Das ist ja gut, okay. Es gibt in Vorstädten ja oft diese, ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, diese, es sind keine Blitzer, es sind nur so Geschwindigkeitsanzeigen, wo dann deine Geschwindigkeit steht und dann kommt entweder ein Smiley oder ein Frownie oder ein trauriger Smiley. Eine tote Familie. Und Geigen einfach so. Und was bei mir immer den Instinkt hervorruft, schneller zu fahren.
Weil ich will eine höhere Zahl sehen.
Ich will einfach nochmal Gas geben, weil es gibt ja keine Konsequenz.
Vor allem sind die, und da machen die einen strategischen Fehler, die sind nur zweiziffrig, die Zahlen.
Und genau was passiert, wenn ich hundert fahre?
Es ist oft in dreissiger...
In der Spielstraße.
Ja, es ist oft einfach in dreissiger zu hundert Spielstraßen und es ist zweistellig.
Da denke ich mir noch oft, was mache ich jetzt denn, wenn ich mal ein bisschen beschleunige, mal ein bisschen aufs Gas drücke, mal gucken, was dann passiert. Ich bin ja auch in der Siedlung aufgefahren mit Spielstrassen mit Schrittgeschwindigkeit, wo dann auch groß auf der Strasse stand, 5 kmh, wo ich mir immer schon mal dachte, Leute, kein Mensch der Welt fährt 5 kmh, das ist einfach zu niedrig. Du musst realistische Ziele setzen, sonst ignorieren Leute einfach Gesetze. Schreib fünfzig. Du musst ja dann bei Schrittgeschwindigkeit den Fuß vom Gas nehmen. Macht doch kein Mensch. Motor. Macht doch niemand. Einfach den Motor laufen lassen. Standgas. Standgas. Ach, diese ganzen Begriffe. Standfahrt. Angegenab, ich dachte jetzt, du musst die Nebelrückleuchte anmachen. Wirst du sofort an deinem machst. Nebelrückleuchte? Ja. Ist es dasselbe wie die Nebel? Ja, diese ganzen Fragen ploppen bei mir auch auf. Tatsächlich, ich war ja manchmal gerade to go und ich krieg es nicht hin, beim Smart den Scheibenwischer für die Heckscheibe auszuschalten. Schaff ich nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Die ganze Zeit winkt er. Wenn ich einsteige und ich zünde und dann ist es dieser kurze Moment des Bitte nicht und dann dann ist er jetzt halt an und trocken und kratzt er halt auf trocken, was auch unangenehm ist. Aber er kann dir nicht helfen. Was auch scheiße ist, bei dem, komm, wir machen mal kurz ein Car-to-go-Rant. Was auch nervt ist, du machst es an und abends. Ich habe nämlich ein automatisches Licht. Ich kann das nämlich anlassen bei mir im Auto. So, und dann abends geht ein automatisches Licht an. Genau wie tagsüber automatisches Licht an. Ich fahre immer mit Licht. Und wenn ich den Motor ausmache, mache ich es auch nicht aus. Heißt, das ist die ganze Zeit Licht an. Bei den Smarts musst du Licht extra anmachen. Es hat aber so ein Standlicht. Heißt, du weißt ja nicht, wie hell das Licht sein muss von dem Smart, machst den Motor an, siehst ein Licht aufploppen und denkst dir, wow, ready to go. Ich fahre durch Köln entspannt, wink den Leuten den Fussgern zu, ciao, hey, ich fahre nach Hause, alle blicken mich an, hinter mir werde ich kontinuierlich angeblinken, die ganze Zeit angehubt, neben der Ampel, steigen Leute aus, klopfen gegen mein Fenster, ich denke mir, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, seit wann ist Köln eigentlich in der Maserkastung? Mein Gott, die Leute, man kennt mich halt aus dem UFO. Mein Gott, ey, müssen die mich die ganze Zeit ansprechen. Ich will nach Hause. Bis mir aufgefallen ist, sie haben kein Licht an, hat dann jemand gerufen. Licht, sie haben kein Licht. Licht. Er hat dann so die Fensterscheibe angehaucht und hat dann Licht reingeschrieben, Spiegelverkehr, damit ich es lesen konnte. Ja, und dann fanden wir auf, oh fuck, das ist ganz schön ärgerlich von Smart gelöst, dass die einfach einem nicht sagen. Kein Licht. Die Scheibenwischer-Thematik ist furchtbar, natürlich, und vor allem, du hast ja dann einen Hebel, den rechten Hebel. Links ist Blinker, Licht und alles, rechts ist der Scheibenwischerhebel. Den kannst du nach oben machen. Dann geht vorne der Scheibenwischer an. Dann kannst du noch mal oben machen, dann geht der schneller an vorne. Machst du ganz runter, geht der aus. Dann kannst du rechts draufdrücken, dann geht der automatisch in anderen Geschwindigkeiten an. Dann kannst du den einstellen mit dem Drehrad. Wie soll das hinten überhaupt ausgehen? Wie soll das hinten betätigt werden? Du hast alle... Wie gesagt, ich weiß es auch nicht. Es ist merkwürdig. Und ich habe echt das ganze Ding abgesucht, nach irgendwelchen Schaltern. Und auch dieses Eko kotzt mich immer an, das mache ich auch immer sofort aus, dass der Motor ausgeht, wenn man stehen bleibt. Gar nicht., weil dann bin ich der letzte Depp, der dann irgendwie, wenn er grün wird und alle anfahren, bin ich der, der erstmal irgendwie ewig braucht. Und dann, das ist mir, da bin ich in meiner Männlichkeit mir nicht bewusst genug. Da muss ich einfach mithalten mit den anderen. Das stimmt. Ja, Eko ist auch ein Problem. Aber sonst toll. Car to go. Car to go gibt es ja auch mittlerweile in den USA. Richtig. Ist nur da als Riesen-Hipster-Ding verschrien. Das stimmt, ja genau, wir haben in einer Comedy-Show und Stand-Up gesehen, wo irgendwie Hipster-Car-to-go, wo in Deutschland ist ja eher so ein, sag ich mal, mittelständisches, gutbürgerliches, wer sich's leisten kann, ja, vielleicht so ein bisschen hipsterig, ne, so die Carsharing, also Carsharing, ja. Und es ist auch gefallen, dass alle Car-to-go-Autos kaputte Reifen haben. Bei allen ist dieses Reifenzeichen.
Und man hat sich als Autohersteller, genialerweise, bei der Signalleuchte für kaputte Reifen hat man sich nicht gedacht, wollen wir nicht einfach einen Reifen zeigen, vorne, im Kreis, da das was, hat irgendwer gesagt, nein, nein, nein. Wir nehmen links wie so eine Klammer, wie so eine eckige Klammer auf, aber die wird dann rund. Das machen wir rechts auch nochmal, gleich damit es symmetrisch ist. Und dann zwischen den beiden unterhalb machen wir so eine, wie so Zacken, so Zickzack hin. Und dann in die Mitte, es ist zu viel Platz, machen wir noch ein Ausrufezeichen, okay? Machen wir das so? Alles klar. Gut, Dankeschön, ciao. Und dann ist dieses seltsame Gebilde plötzlich bei meinem Auto zu sehen, beim ersten Mal, beim privaten Auto. Und ich dachte, was soll das denn sein? Und bei Öl hast du diese Ginny-Lampe auch ganz strange? Genau, ja. Habe ich einen Wunsch jetzt frei oder was sagen wir es wünschen? Spiele ein Lied. Das wäre dein einziger Wunsch. Spiele ein Lied. Nicht immer ein konkretes Lied. Du willst einfach nur Musik. Wir haben einen Wunsch ist Spiele-Lied. Nicht mal ein konkretes Lied. Du willst einfach nur Musiken. Wir haben einen Wunsch. Spiele-Lied. Wo auch der Wunscherfüller sagt, nee, komm, da ist noch ein. Naja, und dann hast du dieses seltsame Gebilde und ich gucke nach. Ich wälze dann diesen dicken Schinken, wo drinstehen die ganzen Signaldinger erklärt werden. Und dann sehe ich Reifen. Denkt mir, fickt euch einfach. Das hilft niemandem gerade. Richtig geil, aber da habe ich immer Spaß dran. Manchmal hast du bei Cartagope den Navigationssystemen Touchscreens, die aber aus irgendeinem Grund oft so kaputt sind, dass sie deine Eingabe um drei Zentimeter nach rechts setzen. Halb kaputt ist schlimmer als ganz kaputt. Aber wo dann wirklich mein Ehrgeiz getroffen wird,
wo ich sage, okay, dann tippe ich jetzt die Adresse so ein,
dass ich immer drei Tasten, wie so ein Code,
du fühlst dich wie so ein Spion, der so eine Geheimschrift macht,
wo er immer drei Tasten, und teilweise ist es auch so wie so ein Springer,
so zwei nach rechts, eins nach unten,
und du musst das erst rauskriegen,
aha, wie ist der Code in diesem ganz eigenen,
irgendwie in diesem Enigma-Ding, du bist so ein Codebreaker, und dann kannst du wird es dann, dann fällt dir aber auf, dass du ganz links das A benutzen musst und daneben der Bildtipp aufhörst und dann hast du verloren. Und dann gucke ich immer, ob ich ganz rechts tippen kann, ob das dann überspringt nach links. Hat noch nicht funktioniert, oder? Leider nicht, aber das denke ich mir, das wäre dann genial. Das sind so Momente, wo ich mich wirklich cool fühle. Ich liebe aber auch, und das finde ich ganz toll bei den Cardo-Ghosts, die haben dann diese Eco-Funktion, die habe ich natürlich immer an, als umweltbenusster Mensch, und dann kriegst du einen Eco-Score. Ja, das stimmt. Und den kannst du resetten am Anfang. Ich merke mir immer, was hat mein Vorgänger, oder was hat alle meine Vorgänger zusammen, Eco-Score von 47. Ein Schäfer-Tiese hat keinen Eco-Score von 47. Schäfer-Tiese hat einen Ehrcore von 47. Schepferthiese hat einen Ehrgeiz, einen Ecoscore von mindestens 70%. Und dann fährt er an der Ampel ganz langsam an, entspannt, vor der Ampel, vorausschauend, lange, weit, kilometerweit vor der Ampel. Ich weiß, da hinten ist eine Ampel. Bergab, du fährst bergab, was machst du? Hm, die Brücke runter, lass ich laufen. Vom Gas fahr ich runter.
Du fahrst bergauf, kurz aussteigen, schieben.
Schieben, easy, easy.
Hinter mir gehupt, Stadtköln gesperrt, überall brennende Flammen. Nein, 70%. Nein, 70%. Nicht schlecht. Ich finde, ab 70% darfst du auch andere Sachen machen. Du darfst auch dann ohne Licht fahren oder so. Oder du schaltest den Raketenwerfer frei. Einfach so, du kannst deine so Sachen anlocken. Oder so ein zweites Spieler. Ich überlege einen anderen Motor aus einem anderen Auto einzubauen, nur um den Motor nicht zu belasten und einen besseren E-Motor. Nimm noch einen VW-Motor. Boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, jetzt wachen alle nochmal. Relevanz, wow! Da sind Leute aus den Träumen gerissen worden. Guten Morgen! Ich kann mich auf was beziehen, ich verstehe, die sind trotzdem... Oder die gerade noch eingeschlafen sind. Guten Morgen, hallo Nadine, hey, schön, dass du wach bist. Alle so, wow. Es ist jetzt schon drei Uhr nachts, jetzt wirst du wohl noch mal einschlafen müssen. Deine liebe Podcast-Ufo-Crew sagt, gute Nacht, schlaf gut. Wie gut, wenn Leute plötzlich aufhören, wow, Relevanz, ich kann mich etwas identifizieren. Trump, Trump! Nicht komplett weltfremd, die beiden sind nicht komplett weltfremd. Endlich sprechen Sie nicht mehr über Rücksch... Wisch... Ja, wie wir schon was gemeint sind. Keine Ahnung. Man weiss auch nicht. Kennst du es manchmal, dass du für Dinge den exakten Begriff kennst, ihn aber nicht verwendest, weil du nicht wie ein weirder Klugscheisser wirken möchtest? Ja, mega. Klar. Hermeneutik ist so ein Ding, Transzendentalpragmatismus ist so ein Ding. Sowas in der Richtung kommt sehr häufig vor, ja. Oh, die ganze Zeit. Tatsächlich habe ich das manchmal, wo ich dann nicht, häufig wegen des sage ich einfach nicht, schreibe ich auch nicht in Drehbücher rein. Niemand hat eine Figur von mir jemals geschrieben wegen des Problems oder sowas, weil niemand spricht so, Leute gehen aber immer zu mir und sagen, ja, aber das sagt man eigentlich so und so, ich denke mir fick dich einfach, niemand spricht so. Interessantes Problem, sollte das die korrekte Sprache oder die gesprochene Sprache abbilden, definitiv die gesprochene Sprache. Auf jeden Fall, ganz klar, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Welchen Wort ist das bei dir so? Ach nee, ich denke mir manchmal so, auch jetzt, wenn du tatsächlich bei solchen Sachen, manchmal so im mittelalterlichen Bereich oder so im militärischen Bereich, wo dann Leute falsche Begriffe benutzen. Oder so, aber ich sage es dann bewusst nicht, und ich sage auch oft einen falschen Begriff, einfach um nicht so klug zu wirken. Weil die Leute dann sonst, es schreckt Leute ab, wenn man zu klug ist. Ja, neulich hast du tatsächlich einfach, da habe ich mal kurz in der Pause rüber spielunkt, was du denn geguckt hast auf deinem Laptopchen und du hattest tatsächlich eine Waffe. Du hast den Wikipedia-Eintrag von der Walter P99 oder so offen. Natürlich. Wo ich mir dachte, nein, nein, nein, falscher Pfad, falscher Pfad. Komm zurück, komm zurück. Wir haben dich noch nicht verloren, wir geben dich nicht auf, wir geben dich nicht auf. Und erst mal, wir haben ein paar Meetings abgehalten, ohne dich, hast du ja dann gemerkt, wo wir ein paar Amok-Thematiken durchgegangen sind. Ich würde aber nicht die P99 wählen tatsächlich, also da kann ich euch... Ja, ich weiß, genau das, was du gerade sagst, macht mir Angst. Alles macht mir Angst, was du gerade sagst, weil ich weiß, dass du dir darüber Gedanken gemacht hast, auch wenn du das nicht vorhast, aber du wärst jemand, wo ich Angst hätte, wenn du jemals diesen Amok-Gedanken ... Also wir beide sind sehr reflektierte Menschen, wir machen uns viel über Dinge Gedanken, über die wir uns keine Gedanken machen müssen. Ich hätte mir auch schon oft gedacht, was ist das Beste, eine Art Amok-Glaub zu machen. Und wenn man dann irgendwann mal wirklich so einen Shutdown hat und einfach sowas machen würde, hätte ich vor Leuten wie uns am meisten Angst. Aber wir sind doch viel zu neurotisch, wir überdenken noch alles tausendmal, wir schaffen es nicht, mal eine Frau anzusprechen, wir würden doch niemals sagen, so jetzt, heute, manche Leute, wir werden am gefährlichsten, weil angenommen, wir haben mal so einen Shutdown-Moment, erinnern wir uns vielleicht nochmal an diese zehn Monate aneinandergerechnet, an denen wir uns Gedanken gemacht haben, wie man am besten einen Amoklauf durchführt. Ja, aber wir sind jetzt zu keinem Ergebnis gekommen, weil wir es alle so overthinken, kommen wir nicht zu einem Ergebnis. Weil der Trottel sagt, Jockey schreit. Wir sind ja in einem was wäre wenn ein Beispiel und da wäre es nicht gefährlich. Ja, okay, ich weiß es nicht. Ja. Ich glaube, dass wir vom Verfassungsschutz als ungefährlich eingeschätzt werden. Da würde mich mal interessieren, meine Akte. Ja, mich auch. Vor allem, weil ich am Flughafen eine Büroklammer geklaut habe, in der Sicherheitszone. In diesem... Dasgemeinen sehr erbärmlich und lächerlich, aber in dem Moment dachte ich mir, wow, das ist schon mutig, am Flughafen irgendwas zu klauen generell, absichtlich. Ja, lustigerweise sagst du, dann auch was geklaut. Unabsichtlich. Unabsichtlich. Aber wir brauchten halt, um die SIM-Karte rauszumachen, weil wir uns eine spezielle SIM-Karte für USA gekauft hatten, musste ich halt einen Bürokrammel haben, fast in den leeren Geldtauschstand hinein. Klaust kein Geld? Nee, weil ich sehe, die haben Büroklammer, die gucken mich mega unauffällig, die ganze Zeit zehnmal um und in dem Moment, wo ich die genommen habe, mich umschaue, ob sie es gesehen hat und gehe, wird die Security plötzlich zu unserem Gate gerufen. Aber die haben nie ankamen. Doch, die kamen an, bestimmt, waren da dahinter, der im Stand quasi. Wahrscheinlich kamen die an, haben gesehen, ach, die haben die Überwachungskamera gesehen und dachten, ach, so einer. Die siehst du ja vor allem nicht. Die siehst du ja nicht. Auch wenn man so Präsidenten oder Staatsoberhäupter sieht, gibt es ja auch immer so die Secret Service Leute, die mit schwarzem Anzug. Aber ich denke immer so, die richtigen Secret Service Leute sind doch ein Publikum. Die haben doch irgendwie so ein Make America Trump Again Cap auf. Die richtigen Secret Service Leute sind seit Jahren mit dir befreundet und fliegen mit dir nach New York und geben sich seit Jahren als Comedy-Autor aus. Oh, jeez, das war ein Moment, ey.
Das war ein dramatischer Höhepunkt.
Gerade, weil ich, Schleif und Titz,
wollte ich nicht in den Klettverschluss betätigt,
während diesem dramatischen Moment.
Mir ist natürlich ein Szenario
eingefallen, über das ich kurz besprechen wollte,
weil ich es beeindruckend beachtlich finde.
Abtreibungsgegner
sind Trottel. Wissenschaftsverleugnende Trottel.
Leute, die für Abtreibungen sind, kennen die Fakten, wissen, ab wann ungefähr Leben entsteht und entwickelt wird,
oder bis welchen Moment man abtreiben soll, welchen nicht.
Jetzt ist die Wissenschaft auf dem Gebiet aber noch nicht so weit.
Aber sollte es irgendwann mal Erkenntnisse geben, sind das die ersten Leute, die sagen, ja klar, akzeptiere ich, klar, wie es jetzt ist. Jetzt könnte es aber zu dem Moment kommen irgendwann, dass irgendwer mal rausfindet, fuck, dass Spermien leben schon und entwickeln schon Leben. Oder haben Bewusstsein, ja. Oder haben schon Bewusstsein. Ist ja nicht ausgeschlossen, soweit ist man halt noch nicht, dass eine ganze Gruppe Menschen, die seit Jahren für etwas kämpfen, plötzlich alle sagen müssen, okay, ich glaube, wir sind jetzt genau das, für das ihr gerade die ganze Zeit gegen uns seid und komplett einfach 180 gerade Seiten wechseln müssen. Das ist der Walk of Shame, auf die andere Seite der Demonstration zu laufen. Weil das gemeinschaftliche Glauben der Gruppe an die Wissenschaft zwingt, komplett die Seiten zu wechseln. Ich finde das so lustig und hoffe, dass es in diesem Moment mal irgendwann kommt. Ja, das ist schon abgefahren. Man kann ja irgendwann auch mit Embryos sprechen, oder? Ja. Also ich meine, irgendwann kannst du ja Gedanken lesen. Irgendwann können Embryos twittern. Ja, und dann, klar. Ziemlich langweilig heute mal wieder. Meine Frau, meine Mutter schläft die ganze Zeit. Meine Mutter schl Fruchtwasser bekommen. Wieder Kirsche. Lame. Lame, lame, lame, lame, lame. Ich will endlich mal Alkohol. Ich will mal raus. Ich will die neue Staffel Mass of None sehen. Leute, was ist los? Haut mal was raus. Ich will die Babyboss sehen. Folgt mir auf Instagram. Instagram. Alle Bilder sind gleich aus von allen Embryos, die ganze Zeit schwarze Bilder. Ist das ein Account? Embryo? Embryo 001 oder sowas? Ja, die machen nur Zahlen, das stimmt. Ja, finde ich gut. So ein Instagram-Account, Embryo, und dann auch so Instagram-Stories. Ich hoffe, ich werde ein Mädchen. Oh, Mädchen, hoffentlich. Mädchen sind cool. Oh nee, heute habe ich so einen Jungstag, klassischen Jungstag. Ich glaube, ist ein Embryo alles bis zur Geburt oder gibt es auch einen Punkt, ab dem man kein Embryo mehr ist? Oder ist es einfach der Begriff für noch nicht geborenen Menschen? Weiß ich nicht genau. Keine Ahnung, unsere Wissenssendung wurde leider abgesetzt, weil wir nicht so wirklich Ahnung hatten und oft die Diagramme nicht erklären konnten, die da projiziert waren. Deswegen kam es da nicht zu einer Verlegerung mit dem Vertrag, aber naja. Rückblickend nicht zu erklären. Wir sind zurück aus den Ferien und erstmal vielen Dank für die coolen Bilder, die gekommen sind zu Antenne Askar-Bahn. Ja, mega cool. Vielen Dank für das Feedback, wir lassen es jetzt auch sein. Vielen Dank auch für die ganzen Korrekturen, danke, wir lesen uns das alles sehr aufmerksam durch, wir wollen nicht mehr lernen. Ey, ich finde das wirklich spannend. Ich finde das wirklich, viele Sachen fand ich sehr spannend, die gekommen sind,
die ich so nicht wusste und die wir uns
vielleicht hätten vorher zu Gebüde führen müssen, aber
bald kommt es an Herrn Alabastia.
Yay,
nee, mal schauen, mal schauen, ob wir
Bock haben, ansonsten freuen wir euch,
euch wieder zurück zu begrüssen,
zum neuen Jahr, zur neuen Staffel, das Podcast
jetzt wieder regelmäßig. Bis zum nächsten Mal,
bis in einer Woche, macht's gut, bis dahin, ciao, wir heben
ab, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub,